this video is brought to you by
manscaped.com
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
if i say the words thunder lizards to
you
what kind of creature comes to mind
usually when we think of a lizard we
imagine
a small scaly reptile quietly darting
here and there
but thunder lizard implies some kind of
colossal beast
one whose wading plods are accompanied
by the sound of
zeus's most tremulous rumbles but this
mythical sounding creature did actually
exist then it didn't then it did again
the brontosaurus which means thunder
lizard
in greek is one of the largest animals
to have ever walked our planet
at 23 meters with a long neck and even
longer tail
but the brontosaurus has a history
fraught with conflict
it's a war baby you see well
a bone war baby to be precise
and the unfortunate casualty of the
bitterest feud
to ever rock the vicious world of
paleontology
this is the story of the bone wars
if you've watched my channel for a while
you'll know i'm a huge fan of
manscapes and their performance package
kit
the world's first all-in-one men's
grooming kit
that makes trimming the hedges safe and
easy
so your lawn is in order but
gents what are you doing to seal a deal
introducing the new refined cologne
signature sent
by manscaped it's light and approachable
but with a pleasing masculine scent
ideal for the refined gentleman that you
are
refined is calming and inviting on the
nose
with a light citrus burst before
settling into the anchoring notes
of vetiver eventually landing on a
woodsy
masculine finish this 50 milliliter
spray cologne is hypoallergenic
cruelty free dye free paraben free
and 100 vegan and you know what since
father's day is fast approaching
i truly couldn't think of a better gift
than refined cologne
by manscaped for your dear father
the performance package kit includes the
waterproof lawnmower 3.0
the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer
the crop preserver ball deodorant and
the crop reviver ball toner and
two amazing free gifts the shed travel
bag
and the fetching manscaped anti-chafing
high-performance boxer briefs go to
manscapes
forward slash 42 today
and get 20 off and free international
shipping
plus two free gifts link in the
description below
your balls and your body will thank you
america's gilded age in the late 1800s
was a good time to be alive
thanks to rapid economic growth cities
were growing larger
the railroads were expanding and most
people were pocketing better wages for
their work
so much so that people have plenty of
spare time to go out across this
fairly recently colonised continent with
spades and
teeny tiny brushes in hand to do a spot
of fossil hunting
and boy did they this period has been
called
the great dinosaur rush it was intense
and as ruthless as you like it was also
a particularly lucrative endeavor
paleontology has existed in some form
since 5th century bc
in greece but it wasn't until charles
darwin published on the origin of
species
in 1859 that the field took the form
that we recognized today
since the focus of paleontology then
shifted to understanding
evolutionary paths and naturally
fossils became the must-have fuel for
the
engine of scientific discovery a good
specimen could set you back
more than 200 pounds in today's money
that'd buy you a decent car but the two
main men who fought on the front line of
the bone wars
leading the charge weren't just in it
for the cash
well if they were they failed
drastically
they were driven by a mix of academic
distinction
an insatiable first for knowledge and
good old-fashioned ego history is
littered with professional rivalries
there's coke versus pepsi bill gates
versus steve jobs
mark zuckerberg versus human emotions
but
for sheer animosity nothing
comes close to the rivalry of edward
drinker cope
and off neil charles marsh this pair of
pioneering paleontologists resorted to
petty one-upmanship bribery
corruption fraud and outright
felonies in an attempt to discover as
many new species of dinosaur as possible
and sabotage each other's careers in the
process
but this epic feud started life
as a friendship in the winter of 1869
cope and marsh first crossed paths in
berlin
cope was a promising paleontological
researcher
who was traveling through europe to
visit famous museums
rubs shoulders with esteemed scientists
and conveniently
avoid being drafted for the american
civil war
marsh however seemingly unsatisfied with
having just
two university degrees was now studying
for his third
at the university of berlin although the
two shared an
intense fascination with dead things
they came from very different
backgrounds cope was raised by a wealthy
quaker family in philadelphia
his father wanted him to become a farmer
but he repeatedly rejected the idea
and focused on pursuing his true passion
natural history his big break came when
he finally convinced his father to pay
for some university classes which
allowed him to study
under joseph lydie one of the most
influential
anatomists and paleontologists at the
time
cope didn't hold back on sharing his
scientific insights with the world
by the time he met marsh the ambitious
23 year old
had already published a whopping 37
papers marsh on the other hand had an
impoverished upbringing in new york
but fortunately he had one hell of a
rich uncle
george peabody who paid for his
university education
built him a museum of natural history
placed
marsh at the head of that museum and
left him with a hefty inheritance
now that's how you uncle the two had
very different personalities too
cope was young charming and charismatic
but he also had a quick temper and foul
mouth
so foul in fact that his friend claimed
no woman was safe within five miles of
him
marsh nearly 10 years cope senior was
studious
methodical and more of an introvert it's
possible that even when they met
marsh would have seen cope as a bit of
an amateur given that he hadn't really
put the time in academically
but was publishing papers at the speed
of a caffeine fuel velociraptor
the affluent kobe on the other hand
might have looked down on mars for being
a little uncouth and quite frankly dull
despite their differences the pair
seemed to hit it off at first
mars took cope on a tour of berlin and
they spent several days together
no doubt passing the time with long
animated discussions
about each other's bones after they
separated
they often wrote to each other and
exchanged manuscripts
fossils and photographs they even named
new species of dinosaur after each other
and if that
isn't a bromance i don't know what is
but their professional love affair would
not last
not long after the pair returned to
america
cope invited marsh on a guided tour of a
new jersey clay pit
owned by william folke this was a
propitious pit for fossil hunters
miners regularly discovered the remains
of creatures
that had lived along the coast more than
66 million
years ago it was where folk had
discovered the first complete
dinosaur in north america and it was
also where marsh
realizing the potential of the quarry
fired the opening shot
of the bone wars he secretly bribed folk
to send him all the best bones
instead of cope when cope found out he
was livid
marsha's sly opportunism had eternally
soured their friendship with distrust
but marsh was just warming up his true
first blow
targeted copes pride a military doctor
discovered a large aquatic dinosaur
fossil
and sent it to cope cope was elated at
this
novel specimen and immediately gave it a
name
elasmosaurus but as he stared at his new
darling
adorning his tabletop he had a decision
to make
all the bones fit together rather
patently
except for the head he didn't know which
end to put it on understandably he
decided its skull should sit
on the short bit rather than the really
long
tail-like appendage but he got it wrong
elasmosaurus's head belonged on the
opposite side
joseph lydia spotted the error but
marsh seeing an opportunity to disparage
cope
publicly stole all the credit for
apparently noticing the mistake
first and well he approached it with
about as much tact
as billy mays gave to a vegetable
chopper
he gleefully pointed it out to anyone
who would listen
and to say that cope took it badly would
be an
understatement completely mortified
he did the equivalent of deleting
several years worth of your tweets
before a job interview he attempted to
buy
and destroy every single copy of the
journal
in which he'd published his mistake but
it was too late
the damage had been done and his
reputation took a hit
this was especially mean-spirited and
hypocritical of marsh seeing is he was
prone to making
equally embarrassing mistakes all the
time when he discovered his
own longed-necked dinosaur in 1877
he named it apatosaurus tragically
his specimen was missing a skull so
in an attempt to outpace his opponent
marsh did what
any resourceful paleontologist would do
he simply
looked around his lab and took a skull
he found lying around
and stuck it on there years later whilst
examining
yet another longed next dinosaur you'll
notice a trend here
he failed to recognize it as an
apatosaurus
due to it having the correct skull and
instead gave it a new name brontosaurus
marsh's mistake was flagged up by
scientists in 1903
causing the name brontosaurus to fall
out of use
but just a few years ago a new study
found that the original apatosaurus and
brontosaurus fossils
are in fact different enough to belong
to separate groups after all
so marsha's beloved thunder lizard
is now back for good life uh
finds a way following the crippling blow
of the brontosaurus scandal
cope began to fight back and his first
move was to trespass on marsh's bone
hunting turf
he even recruited some of marsh's own
workers
for an expedition to wyoming and thanks
to their expertise
discovered dozens of new species when
mars found
out about his own men's betrayal he was
furious
they initially tried to pacify him with
a spurious excuse
claiming they were trying to lead cope
on a wild goose chase
away from all the good fossils but it
turned out they'd actually quit working
for him
because he was rather flaky at paying
them by the 1870s the bone war
really kicked into gear and shady
tactics
gave way to open hostility it began with
a letter from two men working on the
union pacific railroad
william reed and william carlin the
letter
addressed to marsh claimed they had
discovered a number of large fossils
in como bluff a long ridge in wyoming
but marsh and cope's rivalry was well
known by then
and so the men hinted in their letter
that they would sell their findings to
the highest bidder
marsh took the bait but well aware of
how
ugly things can get on the dinosaur
frontier
insisted on sending armed guards to
supervise the digging
and instructed them to keep cope out of
the area at
all costs to marsha's delight komo bluff
turned out to be a dinosaur graveyard
and it wasn't long before wagons piled
high with bones
were making their way to him and these
weren't just any old bones they included
the first ever specimens of stegosaurus
allosaurus and apatosaurus which may
sound like deleted words from a mary
poppins song
but this was the fossil motherlode
despite being urged by marsh to keep
their lips sealed about the discoveries
reed and colin went behind his back and
leaked the story to the local press cope
reading this news
decided to get in on the action he hired
his own students as spies
to snag intel on marsh's digs
and eventually sent in dinosaur rustlers
armed thugs who threw stones at marsh's
team
attempted to steal fossils from right
under their noses
and shout the occasional torn such as
i beg to differ edward cope found that
fossil
no more than an hour ago it wasn't long
before
cope set up his own digs in komo bluff
and at one point tension between the two
teams
grew so intense that things nearly
escalated into a
full-blown gunfight each man's team was
so wary of the other gaining any kind of
advantage over them
they both resorted to destroying any
fossils they left behind
to prevent them from falling into the
wrong hands
and even went as far as to blow up their
own sights
to prevent the rival team from combing
back over them
away from the battlefield cope and mars
were just as malicious
it turned out that mars despite being a
bit of an old grump
was an excellent networker and thanks to
some very useful connections in
washington
he was appointed as chief paleontologist
of the u.s geological survey the
position secured him with federal funds
and political influence so what did he
do with his newfound power
you guessed it he used it to deliver a
lethal blow to cope
by cutting him off from all government
funding to add insult to injury
he even tried to seize copes's fossils
on the ground that they were the
government's property cope attempted to
recover by investing in silver and gold
mines in the west
but he lost even more money as a result
following a decade of financial decline
cope lashed out once more
this time taking his vengeance to a
whole new level
fortunately he kept an elaborate journal
of
every single mistake and misdeed
his rival had ever made diligently
adding to it over the years
and keeping it hidden in the bottom jaw
of his desk
in 1880 he finally decided to play his
last card
and dished the dirt to a journalist at
the new york herald
no doubt intentionally targeting marsh's
birthplace
the paper's first article titled
scientist
wage bitter warfare accused marsh of
plagiarism
and the mismanagement of government
money sparking a public slang match
that would drag the field of
paleontology through the mud
the scientific community was appalled
not least because cope and marsh had
name-dropped several other leading
paleontologists during the debacle
but none of them came out worst and cope
and mashed themselves
marsh was eventually removed from his
position within the u.s geological
survey
and ironically forced to hand over his
own fossil collection
meanwhile copes's relations with the
president of the university of
pennsylvania
deteriorated for both men the decades of
trying to outdo each other
depleted their finances leaving them
with next to nothing years later as cope
lay on his deathbed
in his personal museum surrounded by
fossils
stuffed animals and reptilian pets
he issued one final challenge to his
nemesis
a head-measuring contest like many
others at the time
cope believed that brain size was a
measure of intelligence
and so he donated his brain to science
after his death
in the hope that it would turn out to be
larger than marshes
however marsh never accepted the
challenge
which if you ask me was a clear sign of
defeat
we'll never know what cope died from as
there isn't any real
evidence to support the rumors that he
was infected with syphilis
after a string of love affairs but
whether or not he did keep his bone
confined to his lab
we do know that he was delivering
lectures and publishing papers
right up until the bitter end as for
marsh
he died two years later from pneumonia
david sanoff an american businessman and
radio and television pioneer
once said that competition brings out
the best in products
and the worst in people a fitting
epithet for the bone wars
if you ask me the bitter feud between
them left a dark stain on paleontology
due to their very public laundry washing
and
the countless scientific errors they
made in the rush to name
new species it also drove two bright
minds to social
and financial ruin in fewer than 40
years
as a scientist cope published more than
400 scientific papers and discovered 56
new dinosaur species marsh discovered 80
making him the winner of the bone wars
if reduced to a numbers game
but putting pettiness aside i think we
can safely say
that the true winner was everyone thanks
to the resulting
unprecedented advancement of
paleontology
and a greater understanding of the
natural history
of our planet thanks for watching